よわぁああ！
こんにちは！
ドクターーーーーーーーーーーー
はじめだ
お久しぶりです
今日は実験的なことをやっていこうと思うんですが皆さんは紙飛行機ご存じでしょうか
先ほども見たと思うんですけど投げると飛びます
そりゃそうだわ
投げると
今見てもらった通り飛ぶわけでございます
飛ぶって言ってもそんなめちゃくちゃ飛ぶわけではないんですよね
これくらい
多分飛んでも10メートル飛ぶか飛ばないか
くらいの記録だと思うんですよね
そこで私は考えた
こちら！
サーキュレーター
あれですね、送風機ですね
回すと
風が起きます
今回このサーキュレータを使って
あることをしようと思います
え、えーー！
うわ！
ということで今回こちらに
大量のサーキュレーターを準備しました
紙飛行機って、こう、空気の流れに沿って飛ぶんですけども
風がこう吹いてる方向に投げると速く飛ぶのは分かるし
風がこう吹いてるときに投げるとあんま飛ばないの分かるし
風がこう吹いてるときに投げるとこう曲がるし
風がこう吹いてるときにこう投げるとこう曲がる
要するに紙飛行機は風の力で飛ぶので
風の動きを自らサーキュレーターで作り出すことによって
ひょっとしたら紙飛行機、永遠に飛べるのではないかと思いまして
要するにこうことです
微調整は必要なんだろうけども
こういう感じで円を作ってサーキュレーターを回します
ちょっと上向きね
多分この状態で今全部のサーキュレーターを回すと
風が
ちょっと上向きに回転します
こうね、ちょっと上向きにこういう感じに回転するんですよ
今のバカっぽいな
こう左上向きの風を回すことによって
紙飛行機を投げると
こうこうこう
こうやって永遠に紙飛行機が回転するのではないか
永久機関
永久機関のように紙飛行機が――
永久機関的に紙飛行機が回転するのではないかと
私は思ったわけですよ
というわけで実際にやってみようと思う
では行こう
めんどくせぇ
よし、おっけー
ということで無事、サーキュレータ―全部回りました
風的にはいい感じです
大分強いです
これ行けるんじゃないですかね
一回紙飛行機をこの渦の中に入れてみましょう
もっとスピード？
ちょっと風が強い
全部風、中でやってみましょう
なんで？
ちょっと輪を広げてみます
これでかなりいい線きたっしょ
作戦変更します
もっと大きな円にして風を強くしましょう
結構広めにとりました
これなら多分いい感じに回ってると思います
もうこれティッシュとかでもよくね
ほら、あ……
惜しい
では飛ばしてみましょう
これは結構いい線行くんじゃないかな？
もっと内側だ、お前らもっと内側
あーー
こういうことじゃないんだよなぁ
＾＾